48 hours is investigating two Cold Case
murders near a popular Colorado ski
resort Annette shinney and Bobby Joe
oberholtzer were both killed on the same
night in 1982 just outside Breckenridge
now their cases remained a mystery for
almost four decades in her first
investigation for 48 hours CBS News
correspondent Natalie Morales reports on
what led investigators to the Killer
on the night of January 6 1982 an
airline passenger flying above this
mountain pass outside of Breckenridge
Colorado noticed a series of flashing
lights coming from below that look like
an SOS a call for help it came from the
driver of a truck stranded in a raging
snowstorm Dave Montoya a local fire
chief at the time went to the location
after the pilot radioed down the
coordinates what were you thinking as
you're driving who does that I thought
it was a tourist what Montoya didn't
know then was that he was about to
rescue a man who had just murdered these
two young women Bobby Joe oberholtzer
and Annette schnee it would take
investigators nearly 40 years to make
that connection we Muse about whether or
not we were going to die before we
solved this case back in January 1982
all investigators knew was that Annette
schnee was last seen around 4 45 in the
afternoon
Bobby Joe disappeared hours later says
then Colorado Bureau of Investigation
agent Jim Hartke Bobby Joe oberholtzer
was last seen in Breckenridge at about 7
30 in the evening the following morning
Bobby Joe's body was found a bloody
glove lay in the snow near her
belongings Annette's remains were
discovered six months later about 10
miles away but in a strange twist it
would be these orange booty socks that
linked the cases one of the socks was
found on Annette schnee's left foot and
the other was recovered near Bobby Joe
oberholzer's body this is amazing this
ties the cases together but it wasn't
until nearly four decades after de
Montoya saved that stranded motorist
that DNA revealed the identity of the
killer as Alan Lee Phillips everything
catches up you know get away with
anything for forever
you don't get away with everything for
anything forever that's true Natalie
Morales joins us now good morning to you
Natalie good morning a lot of little
twist in this because the night of the
murders we're going to learn the local
Fire Chief unknowingly helped the Killer
and then it turns out that they knew
each other they explained well they in
fact Dave Montoya went up there thinking
as he said I thought it was going to
rescue a tourist he gets up there he
realizes huh this guy is the guy I work
with in the mines Alan Phillips so he
Alan Phillips that day said he had been
drinking too much wanted to avoid the
police on the highway so he decided to
take the mountain pass and that's where
he got stuck and because he knew him he
thought oh I know Alan's okay yeah and
he did report though what happened and
you know rescuing him and that actually
made local news there so they had a
record of him being saved and rescued on
that very night that these two young
women disappeared DNA evidence was
crucial where'd they get it from yeah
the DNA was found on the belongings of
Bobby Joe it was near her belongings
love and a bloody tissue some of the DNA
was hers of course but the other DNA
they didn't have a match and the
database didn't exist back then CODIS
was not around at the time until later
in the 90s they ran it through the CODIS
database that's the criminal DNA
database there were no matches there it
took only in the last two years where
they've created this ancestry DNA type
testing genetic genealogy that they were
able to run the DNA and they came back
with two names and one of the guys was
still living there in Breckenridge or
not far from Breckenridge Colorado
Natalie Morales it's good to see you and
have you in studio thank you so much you
can see Natalie's report last seen in
Breckenridge on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 Central right here on CBS and on
Paramount Plus